good evening welcome to tucker carlson
tonight just a few hours ago the Fulton
County Georgia District Attorney Paul
Howard jr. charged former Atlanta police
officer Garret Rolf with murder in
addition to 10 other criminal charges if
convicted
Rolf faces execution the alleged crime
at the heart of it is the shooting of a
suspect called Rashard Brooks we told
you the details of it two nights ago
last Friday race guard Brooks passed out
drunk in the drive-through lane of a
Wendy's in Atlanta Brooks his car was
blocking traffic so restaurant employees
called the police they arrived Ralph and
his partner they woke Brooks and they
asked him if he had been drinking Brooks
admitted that he had been officers then
move forward with a textbook DUI arrest
nothing unusual but when they tried to
take Brooks into custody Brooks started
swinging he fought the officers to the
ground and then snatched a Taser from
one of them and tried to use it against
officer Rolf when Brooks raised the
Taser to fire Roth shot and killed him
here's some of the video hey sir the
driver will stop very good future that's
it how many one in half like I said I
was into the second cup I wasn't leaving
I told her babe let's go to cook I'm
hungry what kind of drinks did you have
I'm not sure if some she ordered she
said top shelf or whatever this already
had about one and a half drinks but you
don't remember what kind of things you
want no fun all right I really don't
miss all right I think you've had too
much to drink to be driving chance on
your back for a chance
after the shooting officer Roth tried to
keep Rashard Brooks alive he performs
CPR on the man he'd just shot mr. Brooks
keep breathing Rob said keep breathing
for me no matter how much you look at
these videos or how closely it's a
tragedy
every time a father of three girls is
dead the question is was it murder ask
yourself how do you think you would do
regardless of what color you are
if you snatched a cop's taser and tried
to shoot him with it most likely you'd
be dead no one would march in your
memory no one would burn a building in
your name no one would consider your
death controversial much less a racial
Act that's what happens when you attack
police officers with their own weapons
everyone knows that but in this case
things are very different
officer Rolf is facing the death penalty
he's been charged by a DA who's under
enormous political pressure to prosecute
the mob wants vengeance now they've
expressed that by burning the Wendy's
where Rashad Brooks died to the ground
they've committed violence will they
commit more if he's not charged that has
to be weighing on Paul Howard and not
just that Paul Howard is fighting for
his job Howard is facing a runoff
election soon
Howard is also being investigated for
sexual harassment and for stealing money
from a non-profit so Paul Howard has
every reason to change the subject into
Bhau immediately to the mobs demands and
that's what he's doing during his press
conference
Howard described Rashard Brooks the man
who went berserk on two police officers
and knocked them to the ground as quote
jovial watch Howard's statement here and
compare it to the video we just played
you mr. Brooks on the night of this
incident was calm he was cordial and
really displayed a cooperative nature
secondly even though mr. Brooks was
slightly impaired his demeanor during
this incident was almost jovial jovial
you just watched the tape calm and
cooperative are probably the first words
that came to mind especially the part
where books grab the cops taser and
fired it at him
just two weeks ago this very same
prosecutor one you just saw Paul Howard
noted at a press conference and we're
quoting a Taser is considered a deadly
weapon under Georgia law whatever that
was then by the way it was a Taser it
could very easily have been officer
Roth's gun Brooks would not have known
the difference between a pistol and a
Taser in the middle of a brawl had that
been the case officer Rolfe would be
dead right now and you never would have
heard the story because no one in the
media would have cared enough to tell
you still the prosecutor would like you
to know that mr. Brooks was cordial and
no threat at all mr. Brooks never
presented himself as a threat at the
very beginning he was peacefully
sleeping in his car just a guy
peacefully sleeping in his car and now
he's dead so why were the cops hassling
a man who was just peacefully sleeping
well the prosecutor suggested why
take a guess officer Roth actually
kicked mr. Brooks while he laid on the
ground while he was there fighting for
his life
officer Brosnan actually stood on mr.
Brooks's shoulders while he was there
struggling for his life the demeanor of
the officers immediately after the
shooting did not reflect any fear or
danger
of mr. Brooks but their action really
reflected other kinds of emotions oh it
reflected other kinds of emotions got
that we know what's coming next
guaranteed they're gonna tell us this
was a racially motivated killing and
maybe they can prove that it was were
always open-minded but at this point we
very much doubt it
there is zero evidence of that so far in
the absence of evidence Paul Howard
should not say things like this at press
conferences it makes people hate each
other it tears the country apart which
is the last thing we need right now
Atlanta's Police Department is 58
percent black that's a higher percentage
of black people than the city of Atlanta
itself so explain how systemic racism is
responsible for the shooting and speak
slowly so we can understand cops in
Atlanta know exactly what's going on and
what's likely to happen next there are
reports tonight that many of them have
walked off the job at the beginning of
their shift no doubt many will retire
from the force and leave the police
chief has already quit who'd want to
enforce the law in a political
environment like this you make less than
a plumber everybody hates you you could
very easily get killed you try to defend
yourself and they charge you with murder
no way no normal person would want that
job so who's going to take the job going
forward we're going to get a lot of very
bad people becoming police officers and
that's one of the many ironies here
pressure from the mob will not stop
police brutality it will almost
certainly increase police brutality as
the worst kind of people become police
because who else would want for now
though attacks on law enforcement mean
that many of us have no police
protection at all recently the black
lives matter riots came to Charleston
South Carolina police disappeared what
happened next this hasn't been widely
reported but we thought we'd share with
you it's a transcript of a 911
restaurant in downtown Charleston near
the battery this is a quote
it's the Macintosh restaurant I called
earlier but it's gotten worse the riots
broke into the restaurant and they are
stealing all the money the alcohol
they're tearing up the seats 30
employees are stuck in the courtyard
their barrack
the doors and they're trying to break in
I called maybe 15 minutes ago and
there's still no cops and there are 30
people in danger no evidence the cops
ever came ken Schneider owns a wine bar
nearby in Charleston black lives matter
rioters came for him too he and his
staff repeatedly called the police for
help but no one came ultimately shiner
told the local television station that
he told dispatchers to quote forget it
it's too late my place is destroyed
sunny later said he was completely in
disbelief that the police didn't come
Shriner should consider himself lucky by
comparison people are losing more than
just their businesses in this
environment in New York City murders are
up 25% just this year and that's despite
the lockdowns in just the past month the
number of murders recorded in the city
has literally doubled compared to this
time of year ago it's not really
surprising we saw the same thing
happened in Baltimore after the Freddie
gray riots when you politicize law
enforcement innocent people inevitably
die that is not a partisan point the
expectation the police will come and
protect you is not ideological ask any
liberal who's ever called the police in
crisis and had them not show up it's
terrifying no matter who you vote for
protecting the public from criminals is
not some feature of government we hope
for it's why we have government it's the
whole point of government there is no
reason to have government otherwise it's
the reason we pay taxes if you went to a
restaurant and they refused to serve you
food you probably wouldn't pay the bill
if the restaurant tried to make you pay
the bill you would resist and you would
every right to resist no one should be
forced to submit to theft and taxation
without protection is theft it's the
definition of it the rest of us have a
right to say that in fact an obligation
to say it and don't them distract you or
confuse you with slogans or rioting this
is not about the shooting death of one
man outside Wendy's it's about something
much larger and much more important to
every American no matter where you live
it's about whether we're gonna have a
justice system that treats all American
citizens equally regardless of what the
mob demands it's about whether we can
live peacefully in our own homes with
families without fear confident that we
are protected by the government that we
pay for if the government will not
protect us we should stop paying for it
and that might finally get their
attention